l'ancien fois centrale de versailles
devient pendant un mois un lieu
d'expériences artistiques urbaines à mi
chemin entre galerie exposition la
maison de production qu'à 36 a réuni une
vingtaine d'artistes pour faire vivre ce
lieu inoccupé et trois espaces s'y
distinguent
il ya un regard sur qui nous sommes qu'à
36 de manière de vrai dans l'est dans
les villes et dans l'espace public et
ensuite un espace qui est dédié à au
quartier bernard de jussieu pour donner
à voir ce qui est en train de se
construire et d'advenir et ensuite vous
avez au global une vingtaine d'artistes
qui sont venus intervenir à la fois
qu'il est pire y sont présents ici à la
fois à travers des oeuvres sur toile via
de l'install la sculpture la
lithographie depuis le mois d'avril 2010
9 des fresques murales sur le thème de
la vie nature sont réalisés dans le
quartier bernard de jussieu de
nombreuses rénovations thermiques ont
été faites dans les immeubles de ce
quartier et le but est d'embellir les
murs pignons quai 36 nous a fait
connaître des artistes venus du monde
entier et il y à aujourd'hui et 9 rays
qui ont été réalisés qui sera la
spectaculaire au fond c'est une sorte de
collection d'art contemporain qui est
fait aujourd'hui dans ce quartier
versailles tente aujourd'hui de faire un
parallèle entre les différents arrêts de
mettre en avant le fréchisme et le
muralisme cette exposition ici qui est
une vision va dire plus contemporaines
de l'art urbain qui est avec des
artistes vraiment grands talents venus
un peu du monde entier dans une ville
histoire comme versailles c'est
intéressant justement de dire que la
création elle continua 21e c